I love to hot us they're also the reason
I come back a lot curvier hi I'm Kat
over Auto and I'm a Nicaraguan American
stand-up comic today we're making a
traditional Nicaraguan dish called Figo
done this is my mom's recipe but the
dish itself originates from the town of
granada nicaragua here we're peeling
fresh yuca but you can get it frozen and
pre-peeled just to save yourself time
and effort peeling the yuca can be a
little bit tricky so you want to be
careful what is yuca it's a root
vegetable kind of like a potato but with
more fiber so your body will thank you
later legend has it that the name
Gigaton came from a street vendor in the
town of Granada who called the salad
figured on to market it as an
invigorating salad for local athletes
Nicaragua is a tropical country meaning
it's hot and humid the whole year round
so a cold dish like a salad is very
refreshing when cooking the yuca you
want to be sure you cook it all the way
not underdone because Roy yucca is
poisonous and you get gets pretty sick
when blanching the cabbage be sure to
only put it in for one minute I like to
set my timer for 50 seconds if you go
past 1 minute it'll already be over
cooked this dish is important to me
because it's what we had at my niece's
birthday party when I visited last
December that trip became more special
than I thought it would because might be
my last trip to see my family there for
many years due to the political unrest
and revolution that began there in April
2018
from me being Nicaraguan means being a
fire and Nicaraguan people inspire me
and I am incredibly proud to be a
Nicaraguan American I love to hot us by
the way they're one of my favorite foods
to eat whenever I go visit family
they're also the reason I come back a
lot curvier and I don't mean curvy in
the right places so don't eat this daily
there are many ways to enjoy figure out
when I was cooking this with my mom my
whole family was fighting over exactly
how to make it some people blanched the
cabbage other people don't she doesn't
put in onions because I hated onions
growing up I had no idea it even cold
for onions in the first place no matter
how you assembly whether you want to put
the yucca first mix all together
take out onions put extra vinegar this
is a great dish and I'm sure you're
gonna love it
[Music]